uh of course there is the war which is
which is horrible and and despicable and
and and we completely um
we want this to stop that's clear
but my worry was that that might lead to
a sort of rush towards canada status for
ukraine and here the system is also
crucial it is not a
emotional system it is a political
system and i must say that the
commission really came up with a very
balanced
um outcome brutally honest still a lot
not
a lot needs to be done
but enough has been done to grams can
the state thank you i really appreciate
everyone
countries and my country lithinia is
really keen supporter and vivia from
very beginning the keen support of the
candidate status to ukraine
and i think this political support is
very important for the fighting spirit
of ukrainians they are very brave they
are very effective in fighting against
the aggressor
but they need political support they
need economic military support too
and this is the least we can provide to
them and to continue this
heroic fight for freedom nothing is ever
easy on the balkans but here i think
that you might see well
50 60 percent chance a breakthrough next
week
solidarity
[Music]